hello I'm back this is another
unexpected stream but thought I'd mix it
up let me open up the chat I was hosting
men Feingold for the last couple hours
but now I'm not so what I'm gonna do is
play some games and this is not going to
be chess this is going to be drops good
luck
blitz Singh I've started setting this
game for just a few days now and it's
actually great like it's a great kind of
situation where I'm just a complete
beginner again I'm just trying to kind
of figure things out and I think it
gives me more appreciation for people
who are just starting out chess who
maybe aren't quite familiar with like
all the complex tactical ideas so it's
fun been enjoying some some blitz games
some investigation into opening
principles and strategy and etc anyway
uh let's go for a trade forcing move you
had that pre moved take away from the
center even though I should be
controlling the center in this game I
want my piece here this is a useful
square from at least what I've seen
I'm not playing checkers this is not
checkers this is dropps checkers is is a
slightly different game looks very
similar this is a ten-by-ten board this
is very similar to checkers in the sense
that pieces can jump over to capture but
there are some differences I can try and
explain the rules but I'm playing on the
site it's called lead Roth's org if I'm
not mistaken it's been it's been
launched like a week ago and they cloned
elite chess so they've cloned like the
whole code base so we just and just
changed it to two drops so okay let's
start moving towards the center I'll
start with this
and I want to just improve the position
of my pieces it seems like at the
beginning of the game it's more
positional and then later like later
middlegame it becomes more tactical
hello to people in the chats John
Herschel welcome
I was watching John stream earlier with
honor rudolf it's good stuff what are
the rules so the rules are like checkers
you can take pieces by jumping over like
one square if you can take something you
have to take something so there's
there's a whole concept of forcing moves
what else if you can double jump let's
say you have an option between double
jumping and single jumping you have to
take the maximum number of pieces
let's move towards the center
unlike checkers all the pieces can move
backwards which is actually which is a
bit confusing when you're first starting
out very easy to miss backwards moves
okay what else when you promote you turn
into a king now the queen and the king
can move like a bishop in chess it can
move diagonal
as many squares as it wants and it can
capture by jumping over things I think
that's pretty much it uh oh I see why do
you ask me giving a very good
explanation I think his username suits
his suits his responds very well so like
it's a situation I have two different
options I don't know if it's gonna make
a difference
let's take here first no no I'll have to
take next move
so more trades and okay like like chess
material is a very big factor of who's
better so if I if either players to find
a tactic which wins even one piece I
think that's a very big advantage and if
you can find a tactic to like force a
promotion that's also a very big
advantage so the position is actually
opening up we've traded a lot of things
so far I think I should keep improving
not move this guy it's important to have
like reinforcements sometimes if you
have gaps between your pieces and I have
to take wait oh this is three oh I have
to move quicker I forgot this is blitz
five to move much quicker this is
probably gonna come down to flagging the
guy this is already a tactic because he
had to take an ally triple jump I was
actually an easy tactic but I do have to
play quicker we're going to trade pieces
it's taking a while to take sometimes if
you don't realize you can take it won't
let you play any other move oh wait he's
just disconnected though but now he's
reconnected but he gave me a time
advantage how to avoid blunders it's the
same strategy as chess to avoid blunder
as you have to visualize the move before
you make it and make sure you're not
completely insane
I was another triple jump okay and he's
disconnected good game let's sing yeah
so I apologize for the people who were
looking forward to watching chess but I
don't know this is exciting for me this
is just for fun so I do appreciate the
people who are watching and maybe
enjoying this let's play why'd you ask
me this guy knows the rules because he
basically shared the rules in the chats
but he's a new player looks like it's
played uh he's with a few ultra bullet
games okay this I think is the most
common first move because you want like
you know you want to get the corner
piece and it's just most flexible to
bring stuff towards the center hello
Prince Cassady thanks for your comments
that's very flattering what's the name
of the site the name of the site is in
the stream title leader office org very
similar to leach ass org and I did get
the permission from the leeches Maas to
use leech s in the title so I believe
leech s is featuring my stream right now
even though I'm not technically playing
on their sites but ok they approved it
I'm gonna play here because this these
squares are usually valuable like if
you're on the edge it can generate some
tactics for example like someday if I
play here and he has to take and then
maybe I could like triple jump or
something
I don't know anyway let's play wait a
minute I think he just missed a tactic
no he didn't I was thinking he could
have played here and then take but
that's just a trade so I think I can get
away with this this is a move I kind of
have to be concerned about because it
weakens the sky but I think it's okay
I'm in some money this is not checkers
this is drafts it's a game which I
learned just a few days ago but I'm
enjoying it there's a lot of
similarities between the skein and okay
this game in checkers but this game in
chess
if there's lots of concepts that overlap
between like tactical and positional
thinking and forcing moves and
opposition and sacrifices what else
opening traps and games I'm still very
much a beginner okay so he prevented me
that's probably if I move the one thing
I'll admit I don't really like closed
positions because I don't fully
understand them I actually prefer it if
it's more tactical but I feel like I
have to play positional just gonna
improve my own it's about to say my king
side but whatever the side of the board
the right side I was thinking about this
but then he double jumps that would be
bad so let's improve
you looked on Leech ask for new variants
yeah this is a quite the the chess
variants I was hearing some rumors that
there there's a newly chess variant on
the way had some pretty good inside
source which I'm hoping to actually
check out soon and what to do here just
gonna do this wait that could be be
dangerous I do this first maybe do this
so checkers and drops have different
rules the same concepts apply where you
capture by jumping over things draw
officers the main differences are pieces
pieces can capture backwards and when
you promote to a king it's it's like a
bishop where it can move any number of
squares diagonally so I think it's a bit
more complex than checkers and that's a
10 dot 10 by 10 board so just naturally
more pieces okay I want to trade because
this positions really annoying me oh I
actually might see a tactic here I think
I can play this if he takes this way
then I double jump and if he takes this
way I can take he has to take back and
then I double jump and I win material so
let's go for that the great thing about
the site there is a whole puzzle section
so it's likely chess puzzle trainer
where you just you solve exercises you
got rating points so it's probably the
main way that I've been training drafts
is not solved
I know checkers is solved I don't think
dross is solved but I don't know much
about it I was looking up you like
YouTube videos of drafts I could barely
find anything
I type in drafts in YouTube and only
checker videos come up so it seems like
there's very little content for it and I
have no idea where this game is even
popular I know
evanka got into it for a little bit is
that kind of viral video of Yvonne shuck
playing at the world whoa he's allowing
some triple jump
I was generous of him I think if you
follow chess content at least for the
past few years the von Schaack video
like circled the web or he had some like
incredible drafts gained during some
closing ceremony and they called his
name and to like sprint up to accept his
his trophy okay I want to go here to
destabilize this but then he double
jumps so what to do go here
looks logical now I'm threatening this
I'm not sure how he stops it maybe yes
to play this and we trade
why didn't I came because I have to jump
over something to King these guys are
stuck it's like when pawns are stuck but
pawns are stuck when they're like across
from each other these guys are stuck
there on the edge and diagonally from
each other ok yeah so he's going for
this forcing line I'm gonna play this
because I want to play this force this
and then do this also I don't know
notation because this where is our name
differently pretty sure this is square
46 and this is square five but other
than that I still have some learning to
do I move 13 I miss something I move 13
and I'll see what I missed I mean this
is my only double jump I miss a king on
triple o did I have a triple when I
triple jumped
maybe I missed something okay so I'm
going for this my triple jump ah I
forgot I could move forward okay that
was ooh this is bad
I just blundered back something cuz he
can I forgot he could double jump that's
not good
I guess I'll capture here first and then
see what he does like he's already set
up the tactic but I'm up three pieces
I'm about to lose one back but also be
up to should be okay
so yeah this is a problem like I have to
allow the double jump because next movie
I'll have to take my pot with the
command that's cool that's troll
although that's funny who the people who
joined just have no idea this is it's an
interesting move okay to take now this
scenario has to double jump he can't he
can't single jump he might be trying
this right now and realizing it's not a
legal move he would like to do that and
then I know he would like to double jump
okay so now the problem is he's
threatening this and it's not entirely
clear it's actually a big problem
because I would like to stop it but that
only gets like destroyed so looking for
tactics where I do this and force this
I think much works go for this I hope
he's not winning
sometimes when you like have a piece
separated it's like a it's like an
isolated pawn or like a pawn in the
ponies territory that was a really good
move this is a fork which I forgot he
could play that's unfortunate
so he's coming back like he's winning
material here I think I would rather him
take backwards and then I'll just focus
on a strong Center and yeah let's
continue the move up my plan is to do
this and then this then he would have to
take and then I get rid of this guy he
might have the same plan on on this side
wait what is my plan you forget my plan
oh yeah to do this it's the thing about
about this game at least about being a
beginner I'll play like a full game I'll
have no recollection of what goes on or
like how to recreate the game like none
of the moves like stick in my mind if
like if the position disappears I
wouldn't be able to like set it up and
recreate it maybe I can recreate some of
it but I still know how like that
intimate relationship with the pieces
yet okay so I'm still up I don't even
know what we call a couple pawn up a
piece still don't know like correct
terminology I'm gonna play this
threatening this and then this is some
nice opposition because if you ever
moves here I just capture so
let's focus on improving hey it's a
donation covert donating $20 what does a
message they're almost 1,400 and rapid
thanks to the London congratulations
London is is a great opening feel free
to like send me like if you have
questions regarding anything feel free
to send me questions I will be starting
a youtube series soon where I'll be I'll
be answering viewer questions
ok let's improve let's start with this
be more flexible I'm not sure if I want
to go this way or this way this is
another overlap with chess is the
concept of staying flexible he wants to
do this that's ok play this just going
to try and play flexible moves and not
be too committal Oh move towards the
center ok I actually have to focus
because this is this is a 5 5 game that
I'm a below a minute I'm up material but
as we see things can quickly change due
to blunders if the goal is to play this
okay now I'm spotting a tactic but it
doesn't quite work and start with that
this is a really nice formation it's
called the pyramid formation I just made
that up
now can I do this capture I mean really
nice if it works capture the air capture
and then I quadruple jump he takes back
and I play there I think I went a piece
he goes this way I just called your bull
jump again
ah so he takes that way but now I win
everything and he has to take backwards
and now I'm in good shape
but he just resigns okay I was up four
pieces he would have to take back I
would be up three yeah it's a easy win
okay that was fun that was a nice that's
kind of tactic they're like the
sacrifice where he can take both ways
the great thing is we have the analysis
board can analyze the game there's no
stock fish though I don't know if
there's a droughts engine which exists
but I guess that makes cheating a bit
more difficult also thanks for the host
halvard anyway the plan was I'm this was
a critical line another overlap with
chess critical variation I was planning
to do this so as a double sacrifice to
get the quadruple jump so I would win I
would win a piece here I'd yep okay
here's five and I have I can't count
I have eight no he has six and I ate so
I'd be up to and then I would stop this
guy from promoting probably by moving
here and should be good for for whites
anyway that was fun so the great thing
about streaming this because I was
playing earlier and I wasn't streaming
it was really hard to get a game because
when you go to the homepage you can see
how many players are online zoom in here
I can't even it's hard to show people
but on the home page it says 27 players
online and one game in play and when
there's so few people online it can be
hard to get a game no one in the lobby
but I have for pending challenges so
yeah let's just go in order here I'll
play viewers I'm in some money can i
play chess crying face that makes me
feel bad I've played so much Jess so
like I need a break for chess you I got
you a sub check your records oh that was
not directed at me okay let's start with
this and go right away for the square
I'm still at a point where I'm not
really sure what I'm doing in the
opening but sure most of my opponents
are maybe a bit confused already looking
for tactics cuz this is weak these two
things have no not the best support but
I don't think there's anything yet so
let's move towards the center
have you seen the video Yvonne Jacques
playing droughts with yo bhava yes I
that video just a few minutes ago a very
viral video there's a few other videos
on YouTube of Yvonne ship plane which I
was actually studying just other day
okay so he wants to capture here wait a
minute
then I can double jump he jumps so I
actually have a tempo here maybe set up
a tactic I don't know I don't even know
what to look for
I'm gonna just go for this allow him to
capture and then okay we're trading off
two pieces each play go or something I
actually don't know how the play go I've
never learned I think it's more popular
than this game I guess they need a leak
org it might be a hard domain to get
already looking for tactics just improve
just want to try and control the center
aka color fish calling this a travesty
this is fun I'm enjoying myself hope
people aren't having too depressing of a
time
this looks weakening but is it bad we
could trade it could be to weakening
let's play here just allowing some
supports Jared MW chess this is not
checkers like at least three or four
people have called this checkers so far
this is called drafts I finally I
finally figured out how to pronounce it
today I'm staying at the same house as a
Dutch guy who who knows this game better
than I do
can i play this guy should just move
towards the center again can do this
okay we're still developing opening
principles
so another term which oh my gosh he just
allowed very bad things to happen to him
I didn't even realize like to the final
jump it's so easy to blunder in this
game because like one thing you miss and
then the position just turns very very
bad I think he's losing this guy I guess
he could play this and then we trade or
not he's gonna play this I'm gonna play
this yes to jump in and I double jump
yes okay life is good about five pieces
huge material advantage but the thing
about this game like I don't I haven't
seen too many people just resign but
this position is probably just resign
Noble and then get our position of this
guy and the thing is when you're up so
much material it's much easier to
achieve those long tight positions I
think he's losing more material because
he can't defend like I'm threatening the
double jump yeah like he played this
thinking that after I take he can take
back but he forgot the double jump which
when I first started this game like it
was so easy to miss stuff like that can
now I want to do this I don't think he
can save this guy yeah the backwards
jump this is too much fun now I just
have a massive army this feels like
horde except except this is a different
game oh look at this tactic this is
going to be so much fun
okay now we're gonna see how a king
moves
please don't resign he's gonna resign he
sees with what's gone thank you may be
okay I'll play probably playing on so
now okay this one moves like a bishop
but the capture is like a normal piece
so just to demonstrate I'm gonna move
all the way back and it's so strong cuz
it's like a long-range piece so I want
to kind of start with this now I'm
threatening to double jump actually
triple jump I could take all of these
things and yeah he's in trouble because
this guy can't be defended
and I have enough time I'm up 11 pieces
and I lost a piece
I even know how many pieces you start
with okay now I want to take the sky
okay so now to demonstrate I have three
legal moves here no I have one legal
move I have to double jump yeah and okay
to demonstrate one nice thing about the
interface when you click on the piece
you can see the legal moves so here I
can only take and then I have to take
here and he's got the double jump me so
he got the final tactic but now he's in
zoogs Lang I'll pre move this going back
to the corner okay good game
yeah that was pretty dominant okay let's
move on
we'll play bouncy cats just going in
order this is so much less overwhelming
than Li chess where I have like thirty
pending challenges and I have to use
Siri to to pick a number let's start
with my classic opening to answer the
question from Tech game you know I don't
think there is an engine at least that
I'm aware of comparable to stock fish
I'm gonna play this avoiding this
annoying move and then I'll strengthen
the center
we'll keep reinforcing the center DJ
Ches dog was good seeing you today too
there is a lot of people there were a
lot of people at this autograph signing
I've never seen that many people like
just being like the lobby of the Chess
Club it was pretty insane but that's
what happens when you have like a free
event like all the like the top ten
players in the world it's really cool to
see I'm in the trade so why not
are there drawers in drafts yes there's
a few different ways to draw which I'm
still not aware of like the specific
rules
I think there's instead of a 25 or
instead of a 50 move roll there's a 25
move rule can I do this and survive no
looks dangerous let's do this and
there's no stalemate so if you're in a
position with no legal moves and you
have less pieces you just lose which I
didn't realize until I got stalemated
with like one piece left and I'm just
lost
international drafts has not been solved
it's cool okay this is a move I'm
calculating you just trade stuff
just improve reinforce the center I
think I have better center control and
these slightly more space with good
reinforcements okay so he's reinforcing
I'm gonna go here wait does that should
be okay oh this is a casual game what is
my rating so low confused oh this is a
rapid game because it's five plus five
so I'm used to playing blitz let's
reinforce relatively close position I
would like to initiate some trades I'm
just gonna be flexible to Coombe a 64
came here for chess I'm so sorry I feel
so bad when people say that because I
know you expect just for me and then
when I don't play chess it's
heartbreaking but what to do I'll do
another chest stream probably tomorrow
maybe tomorrow evening keep reinforcing
this is a really close position which
I'm not comfortable with these positions
because I don't understand what's going
on because that might be a oh that would
be a big mistake I think because it
would lead to this I can do this we
could trade more
maybe I can do this no that's bad too
okay let's do this using a lot of time
here
Oh is there a drops category I could
change it
I forgot that I would have to change the
twitch thing too mmm you see what I can
do completely forgot about the game
category I'm so used to streaming chess
Japanese tutor welcome back good to see
you okay I have to take now this is my
target I just I want to trade off
everything it's a slightly annoying
position so maybe I could do wait I see
a tactic I do this
he takes I take he can take backwards
but hopefully he won't wait no that's
just losing a piece for me
because I want to remove this guy to
like destroy him it's not that easy
oh I can just no I can't do this because
he still takes backwards and if I do
this you could trade more let's do this
okay let me see if I can change the
thing please don't report me I had no no
bad intentions game drafts update
information okay wait a minute no not my
lovely daughter drops it like
auto-filled to my lovely daughter
there's no drops category but now there
is I just okay it's a custom a custom
thing I guess what to do maybe this
now do I have loot attic no I still
don't have the tactic I'm just gonna
play another move and trying to manage
my time better this another piece of
strategy which I I saw somewhere is that
you should keep your center piece on the
back rink just because it has the most
flexibility I do this take wait I think
this works
finally a tactic because I double jump
this guy's the the weak points wait what
oh I have a stronger tactic wow I didn't
even see that I was looking for the
double jump and didn't let me do that
because I had a triple jump
ah that was a pleasant surprise it's a
great thing about this game if you have
like a mediocre capture like you have to
play the best capture so now I'm up I'm
up three pieces but I have the King
which is I don't know what the value is
okay now I can capture like this you
might be able to trail it off somehow
actually he has a way to trade that off
by force which he didn't do he could
have done this and I had to take and he
could take but then I would take like
that so now he's running this which
yeah which I probably shouldn't allow
let's go here get safe there and now
okay how life is good
oh I think I see another tactic wait
here take take and he takes like that
then I take back so that's just a trade
I'll take to land here probably oh I can
take here it's a Mahatma static I
thought it's his move and then and I'm
missing these backward captures so that
was just yeah I was pretty clean so
accidental tactics okay
I can do this and now I'm threatening
the double this is like a skewer like in
chess you can't save this guy
you could try and sacrifice this guy but
uh okay
it was nice so now it's time to just
trade I'll win the sky okay
good game my opponent says facepalm in
the chat a good game will you be playing
any chess if I run out of the pending
challenges I'll probably play some chess
by have five pending challenges well
play Thaddeus longer game more time to
think
I've played Thaddeus twice before I beat
him twice
so trying to keep my my streak clean do
I not click update update information I
changed my game two drafts sixty-four
viewers it's a sign that he I should be
playing chess how many squares are in
this board there's a hundred squares but
there's only 50 coordinates because half
the squares don't really count for
anything okay so I'm gonna go for some
opening
just go for this right away let's go for
this seems like he's played I remember
this style of just trying to move all
the back pieces this is very resemblance
of the Hedgehog also thanks for the bits
Japanese tutor what to do let's do this
I like this already like from the
positional stand points I'll probably
achieve the same on this side
I was very well times miss that Hedgehog
cheer cheering for the Hedgehog okay
he's playing solidly everything's
reinforced don't really see any
weaknesses I could initiate some more
trades
I prefer open positions this makes
finding tactics a bit easier
I play the London I'd be curious if
there's names of openings in this game I
was looking up some opening traps on
YouTube was somewhat interesting I think
opening principals like you want to
access these squares and control the
center it's really all I know maybe I
can control the center like this trade
some more you might go for further
trades or not
okay he's doing the same strategy of
reinforcing everything so I should
probably do the same she was like I have
a slight space advantage though because
he has no pieces on this Frank I have
one piece on this rank and one piece on
this rank I don't know if ranks are like
a relevant term in this game but they
probably are because it determines like
I would think space is a an important
element least a positional play space
and center okay well I have some forcing
Moose nothing seems too appealing I
think I'll go for the trailer of this
guy and gain more space maybe I should
take towards this side it feels wrong
but feel like the square is still
important well I'd be coaching droughts
drafts now I could coach drafts I mean
I'm a complete beginner but I'm learning
trying to apply what I know in chess to
this game already I'm looking for this
sort of tactic where it could be really
useful it doesn't quite work yet
I just want to move towards the center
he's gonna play this just watch him play
it it's a reinforcing move
it's it's interesting like with this
game so I I mean it's easy to know this
is in chess but in this game I also know
this like people have their own kind of
unique styles you can play like closed
positions or open positions or safe for
more ambitiously
okay let's
go for this
I'll be an interesting this game will be
interesting because this is a lie the
longest time control I played so far and
we both have enough time to avoid like
silly blunders so this might be a much
higher quality game troll alert look
behind me people were tricking me
yesterday so I was sitting right in
front of a window there's some
reflection in the window I was tricked
many times like Cobras comment Black has
screwed too many weak light squares all
the light squares are weak now he wants
to doubled your own double jump so I
have couple options
yeah before I play every move I'm
looking out for what tactics he can play
like this is another chest concept where
you constantly have to be aware of your
opponent's ideas and I think it's a
really important habit to to acquire
from early on I'd be doing some drafts
lectures for the st. Louis chess club
nothing nothing plans I'm actually
tomorrow is my final day as doing
residency so maybe in the future though
if this game becomes more popular I was
thinking about doing a horror for their
their secret life of pawns class but
never got around to that they actually
cancelled a couple of those classes
because of the tournaments okay let's
move towards the center
yeah things are closing down again to be
careful I'll start with it seems wrong
start with this I think it's too bad and
that looks weakening though what else to
do I feel like I'm running out of moves
I'm just gonna do this there's a term in
this game it's called a fork but it's
nothing like a chess fork a fork is just
a formation resembling the lambda the
lambda letter whatever you call it which
is like this and it's basically a set up
to achieve tactics there's all another
formation called a tail which is just
three in a row I don't see any tactics
yeah this is a bit frustrating it was
like any trade I go for now I can't even
go for trades is any like forcing move I
play just allows him a bunch of captures
am i visiting Quebec Canada I was
invited to a tournament in Canada I
think was Montreal in January I don't
know what the weather is like in January
in Canada but I think it's pretty cold
also I'm probably going to be in
Australia in January or somewhere where
it's it's much warmer okay so I want to
think I can't play here because he
double jumps me can't play here because
he double jumps me play here this has a
very annoying style you'll play this and
just make progress on this side that's
not even a plan though
we're both following the principle of
keeping our last piece on the first rank
January Australia is like plus 40 plus
40 weight plus 40 Celsius I'm used to
Fahrenheit but that sounds really hot I
was in Australia in December last year
and it was actually great weather it was
like maybe 30 high 20s that's right
cuz I forget I forgot Celsius also did
he know he didn't give me any any chance
this is really frustrating and I'm
running low on time
I don't even know what to do so I can do
this just feel like his position is much
more stable than mine
I'm still looking for tactics
and he'll go for like this idea but he
might have some counter tactics if I
play this he would just play this I take
and then he jumps everything so let's go
for this maybe do I go for go for this
first at this point I'm relying on some
kind of intuition looking for a chess
club and Sydney nothing around
I heard they they opened the chest
themed restaurant in Sydney called Queen
side I saw some post on Facebook and
they have they have items on the menu
named after Fionna after Jen jihadi
after ginger GM it seemed like a cool
place antenna using some some ideas of
the kingside diner in st. Louis so yeah
it's something to check out
not comfortable in this position I feel
like I have to get whoo that was a
really good move let's say I was I feel
like I have to get my opponent out of
his comfort zone he's winning a piece
here it's not the end of the world but
it's not pleasant
I would like to deep stabilize this
thing so this is perhaps a potential
target that's hard to do he's so solid
hands like a giant pawn chain in both
directions so I guess I have an option
of going to Australia in January where
it's it's over 40 degrees Celsius or I
can go to Canada in January where it's
minus 20 degrees Celsius it seemed like
a great choice choose a game what they
did you choose a game with the closest
name to draw through your chests for
your for your streaming well at first I
chose something about my lovely daughter
because I guess I typed in DRA ugh and
it thought daughter but now I just
manually typed in drafts and it wasn't
like a pre-selected item but it did
change I think it updated okay so I have
a fork this was my fork it's supposed to
lead to tactics let's see if that's
actually gonna happen
so this is 10 plus 0 so time is going to
be a factor he wants to do this got some
proof
maybe I'll go for this now she seems
like a very reasonable option whoo he's
running some jump there's a few ways to
avoid it
promised he's also having ideas of this
it's really annoying so I'll go for this
we can trade to play much quicker it's
going to do this
this is stressful
so you can go for the same idea wait I
have a tactic now I feel like that just
needs to a trade take take
oh no it doesn't lead to a trade I think
it leads to me winning no I have to
double jump though high so I can't take
here I have to double jump he takes
backwards it's just a trade yeah
it's disappointing oh but I have this
move so I win back material ok
accidental tactic now it's gonna be
equal material I'm down on time but at
least I have some momentum and I have a
good center control - maybe I can go for
this
seems risky though
I just want to put him in zoos long okay
now I have a passed pawn that's a turn
right and this is not actually a passed
pawn because it's blocked or maybe it
it's not Platt okay now I'm gonna use
some wizardry ha but he wins this guy
that's annoying
wait oh I win the sky but my time is
ticking
No
are you serious and that was a rated
game - are you serious
oh it's one final and I'm now slipped at
the end there - I played such a good
game I came back two weeks in slow oh I
didn't know there's my time though
and the moment at the end I thought it
was his move I didn't see I could do
this and this my first loss was my first
lost at Thaddius game I would put
cobbler thanks for the thanks for the
bits slightly uh makes me feel slightly
better but I was tough I think we both
we both miss things that game got really
tactical at the end there I wasted like
at least five seconds so I was wondering
why my time was still ticking okay good
game
okay
like cool down and maybe play one more
let's play let's play a more open
position this game that was really
difficult to play such a close game
I just want tactics come up earlier my
appointment username is interesting
provisional player also now my rating is
1,300 and rapid not a great rating but
if I win this game I'll get a lot of
rating points this is a rating game I'm
playing the Sicilian double pawns are
not a bad thing
double pawns on the edge of the board
and can be pretty powerful
okay let's trade and I want to go here
yeah I'm gonna try and manage my time
slightly better just for the end game or
for a girl hater in the game let's go
hear more trades
now I don't have a tactic I thought I
had a tactic don't like I had a tactic
okay let's move up there are some cases
where it looks like you have a tactic
but just doesn't quite work as long as
you just need more supports he's
reinforcing things I'll play a bit
cautiously I don't like when they do
that though I'm gonna go for the trade
got a piece of the square
I can't trade off that guy immediately
if I go here he would double jump me so
let's go here I want to set up this this
tail formation
it's a beat hacker that's probably good
I changed the name of the game then I
didn't leave it at what it was for a
moment know that okay I just said this
is a bad move
but unlike chess I'm very like forgetful
in terms of like what I'm looking at
oh just uh just re-examine everything
okay let's improve I can improve this
first threatening this just prompting a
trade also chest with Chris thanks for
hosting chest with Chris was streaming
earlier
there were a lot of people streaming
earlier I guess it is yeah it's Friday
night great night for streaming oh let's
take what to do have to improve
and prove further
is this website new I found out about it
just a few days ago I'm pretty sure it's
it's very in you know like it's been
launched very recently it's just a clone
of Li Ches
looks exactly like we chess but I think
it's built by different developers but
the usability I mean I'm used to all the
features and it's fun to like just play
a new game on a familiar platform what
to do let's play don't even know what I
want to do here move towards the center
legally questionable well leech asses
open source meaning anyone could copy
the code and do anything they want with
it I think that's the whole like like
the value proposition of each S value
proposition the right word I mean that's
one of like their their values is that
they what am I trying to say it's so
late like they want people to use a code
and just build things that will bring
users value online so they're not
concerned about people like copying the
code and building another site using the
same same design at least that's my
impression I could be wrong but as far
as I know that's it's a point of open
source
and that's the impressive thing about
leech s like the people who built reach
us are not like paid for doing it like
there's no AG revenue the only revenue
is like donations so I guess they are at
least the main developer is paid in some
way but it's incredible that we chess is
mainly built on volunteer work and just
passion so anyway let's improve actually
he's threatening he has the threat of
this and then I would have to take and
then he jumps a bunch of times in
women's material it's a tricky move very
tricky so I have to do something about
that
I'll probably just play here and now I'm
okay this is another concept of like
identifying weaknesses like these two
things were weak I realized like if
there is a gap between pieces
okay there's always be a gap between
pieces but if there's like adjacent
pieces with no supports then there's all
the potential for the jump so I feel
like being new to a game like this you
have to make a conscious effort to
identify these types of patterns and
then kind of look for them and looked
look for ways to exploit them tactically
so there is increments meaning I won't
flag with one piece left to take I
started noticing opening similar to
chess I've seen a few opening traps but
nothing comparable to chess and the
sense I I wouldn't be able to remember
like three moves deep still not at that
point okay maybe I could remember three
moves deep but in terms of reacting to
what your opponent does it's it's still
pretty difficult because like Chasa can
branch out in so many different ways
that by move a two or three I'm just
trying to figure things out on my own
it's play here some of I wanted to play
earlier now I have I was about to think
about here that he takes and that would
be bad so let's play here create my own
app opening I don't think gambits exists
the only time you sacrifice something is
to win it back like immediately I would
think I could try and invent some new
opening random question about web
development I do mostly front-end I used
to like my first major in college was
math and computer science oh no did I
blunder I don't know if this is so bad
for me though because I should win this
piece back I have to take here first and
then yeah then I can win it back except
he's reading this No
that's not a threat how do I win it back
I could play play this too let's do this
yeah my first major was mapping for
science and I enjoyed aspects of doing
like back and did some projects like I
programmed the rules of chess built some
like interface basically built okay AI
which would just play random legal moves
my program programmed boggle like the
whole algorithm to like solve a boggle
board like reference a dictionary and
find like all the the words to the cool
project using some like binary search
algorithm but then at some point I just
I was really passionate about more
visual media and it's one of the reasons
why I transferred universities was to to
pursue what I ended up majoring in was
interactive digital media and I was able
to pursue it at a school which offered a
chess scholarship which worked out
nicely
no alpha-beta searching let's alpha-beta
I feel like I should know what alpha
beta is but I think I got that far
okay this would initiate a lot more
trades
I'll start with this
oh man I thought my threat was to do
this I forgot he could just double jump
which is a bit bit discouraging but I
survived Prasanna you like my YouTube
videos and you've finally able to catch
a twitch stream unfortunately you you
finally caught a stream at a wrong
moment we're not playing chess
but thanks for thanks for joining
I'm sorry if you were expecting chess
and disappointed but what to do okay I
have to think what to do is the question
night he wants to do this which would be
really annoying so maybe I just do this
I'm just gonna trade that's okay
cruisin sock fish recommends random
moves at best
yeah there's not a great engine it was
fun to play like when it first started
playing legal moves that was a huge
success
switching algorithm used in chess
programs
I know what's the term for the algorithm
that stockfish uses like the min max the
min max to find like the best line
there's something I forget it's been a
while since I can involved in computer
science something there should be
tactics here the problem is the
structure is so solid I should calculate
forcing moves could initiate some trade
yeah let's initiate the trade
no this guy can get here but then he's a
bit stuck so he's just trying to improve
I'll improve as well I'm not in time
which could be a factor both been
thinking a lot maybe I've been just
blabbering more than thinking but okay
let's focus let's play here setting up a
simple trap what she doesn't fall into
I don't know what to do this is an
awkward piece
maybe I do this just trying to stay
flexible I can't I am I am titled beside
my name I'd be cool don't think I
deserve it for this game though
I just I'm lacking coordination it's not
a good feeling
let's move this towards the center
breathing is here low grading and drafts
I am norms I'm just trying to like
understand basic principles I'm not
thinking about norms well I think there
is a competitive draw scene I was seeing
like some videos it like some blitz
championship or something and they were
playing with just clocks and everything
I feel like this is just a bad position
but I'm not down any material yet a lot
of things feel stuck
ok he's threatening to double jump I
might have to move forward you can move
here too maybe I'll do this
it's interesting formation I completely
forgot about that that's a really strong
move but does it work do this he just
takes
I'm in trouble in big trouble
wait I have an idea I have a brilliant
idea oh it doesn't work though it almost
works doing this he has to double jump
then I double jump doesn't he recaptures
huge transformation and probably go for
that anything else
let's go for that yeah so he wins a
piece but now he's slightly more passive
problem is I'm a bit stuck but I can do
this well I can do this and probably
just win back the piece because after he
takes I can take backwards and now he's
losing this guy and now it's ass level
playing field again with the accidental
tactics this is this is five on five I
feel like he has better coordination
here's one pawn island I have like five
pylons but that's okay
I'm gonna coordinate quickly start with
start with this
I have not studied endgames so this is a
matter of trying to figure things out I
have no idea what I'm doing here I don't
know if I should go for the center or
the sides probably the center I'll set
up this tail formation maybe he wants to
do this he wants to do this
interesting
I'm not sure what to do here do this
feel like that's a decent move
I'm thinking maybe I I really don't know
how these how certain concepts should
apply but I'm thinking I could get like
a majority on on the right side but I
almost I mean there should be a
breakthrough if I got a majority so like
if I go for this scared his formation my
pieces again are not coordinated I don't
know for this
that's okay I have a sneaky trap we'll
see if he falls into it I'm low on time
now okay
I'm Fabiano emotes Fabiano is playing
just tomorrow a lot of people are
playing chess tomorrow also I have a new
Magnus emotes I made one just a few
hours ago it should be to be available
to the subscribers he's not blundering
let's go for this
I have a space advantage like I'm
further advanced than he is I know
that's a good thing or a bad thing
because I could be weak but if I hold on
to these guys I could be strong
still have no idea what I'm doing
probably go for this at this point I can
probably just start calculating ahead
because now he's stuck like everything
is stuck except this guy you do this
this is nerve-racking well on time no
idea what's going on I'll go for this
now all these pieces are stuck and this
is stuck so he has to move this lets
only move and the goal is to get
someone's lives long you know he wants
to do this I'm running low on moves too
I think I have to do this
and he's gonna just can't think too much
I just have to move and hope for the
best
oh that's interesting though I have to
take and then he takes backwards
I got a still a good situation maybe I
could even do this and he's completely
stuck no he could do this so complicated
23 seconds left I can do this now
I'm gonna king first because now I'm
okay I'm threatening to win all his
pieces so yeah and now I'm gonna queen
or king always get confused with
promotion and all attack from the rear
now this should be winning
yeah okay I can breathe easily still
maybe have to work maybe do this and
then this and then they're cut off I can
advance
okay I want a game I was exciting I was
an interesting endgame I did not flag
like the previous game final position is
opposition it's my soft position a clap
from Braden I gained over 280 points for
a one win high point lost 260 rating
points was I playing Julian how much
Julian's username is I really didn't
understand the position I don't even
know what to like analyze and already
like I forget what happened most of this
game there is some critical moments
there is a critical moment oh yeah so
this is a critical moment where he plays
here threatening this I have no defense
but then I came up with this resource
and somehow it worked out where after
okay this is forcing this is forcing was
forcing
worked out like okay whites up at peace
but not at the very end of all the
forcing moves I I win this guy and it
was some kind of end game where I mean I
could try and identify the mistake
but maybe I had some positional
advantage because I was playing
restrictively these guys were stuck and
then yeah White's already like very
restricted already here it's just losing
going back so maybe around here there's
some different strategy I don't know
because it seems like white has more
flexibility and weights like what side
the pieces can play on like white can
get a lot of pieces to the side more
quickly but I don't know so I was
playing Julian right here
Oh output coupler said right here if you
want to suggest a move number
you can't run man so the thing about
this game there's no who knows notation
it's hard to suggest moves blade woods
probably just joining welcome this is
dropps interesting game
consumes energy maybe around 30 to 35 oh
like around the critical moments what
was he asking can I run can't I run oh
the right side whenever I try and run he
just captures like this this is always
restricted and if I try and like access
a square then he captures backwards so
Oh from the back Oh like this guy that
was another problem I wanted to play
this move but then he plays this and
he's friending the capture from behind
maybe it's playable I could trade off
it's actually something I probably could
have considered and like playing here or
maybe let's go to analysis board we're
already here like the this was this
whole issue it was was a difficult
position weight output coupler do you
have a user name on on this sites let me
know in the meantime I'm going to if you
have a user name I'll follow you and
I'll make it so you can you can analyze
I'm gonna go to study make a new study
call this mind game analysis oh you
don't have a user name you should make
an account real quick and then I'm
pasting in it's so great this is just
likely chess I'm tasting in this are
game and if you make one real quick you
just need to sign up user name and
password and email address and then I
can add you as a member and then you can
show me where I
I completely messed up Jimmy Ackerman
saying I feel like the concept of pins
and x-ray vision
slightly applies and drops the x-ray
vision yeah there's a lot of a lot of
overlapping concepts I think Tempe
especially in the endgame
Tempe I think are huge if you waste time
or your pieces are further back that's
kind of what happened in that game I
just quicker to promotes just joint
output coupler okay so why Minh Truong
is showing up huh my following so output
coupler you are now a contributor of the
study Oh Minh Truong was showing up
because he's observing
hello Minh Truong now output coupler is
here so you can see the move number and
you can go to the position and just show
me what I could have done that's great
like you can add comments to and comment
don't think the center is important okay
so he's going forward it's probably
better cuz there's a delay with twitch
if you type in your message or you're
like if you have a comment type it in
and like the chat on the study or even
and like comment area okay now I'm
getting a serious question
wait I'm getting a few questions not
more important than the sides be equal
the sides are valuable because a piece
on the side can't really be weak and it
can generate tactics but I feel like the
center also has purpose because there's
just more flexibility in terms of when
you're in the center you can help out
either side so I don't know
there's a if you go to learn and study
in a new tab at least I'm going to new
tab there is this study and the study I
guess I haven't seen this study but
basic structures and systems
I just assumes wait I haven't seen all
of this somewhere I saw you that you
should control this Center wow I've not
seen this whole thing I have to check
the salad get closer oh he's doing
something moved 22 wait I was black
right
you flipped the board Oh
so instead of wait I'm confused
oh because uh wait what why does it keep
flipping I'm pressing F on the keyboard
then when I play a move it flips back I
feel like this is a bug which doesn't
happen in me chess I could change the
orientation it's another thing about
this when you flip the board it's just
completely messes with my perspective
but in chess if you flip the board is
just the same position keeps resetting
any time I click anything yeah there's
probably a bug or if your contributor
you probably don't have full access if
you can't change them moves yeah it's
not as powerful as Li chess yet
unfortunately it seems like there are a
few bugs was this really not made by the
same people who made Li just the the the
framework is probably identical
but uh as far as I understand the whole
codebase was forked and then all the
chess rules were replaced by drafts and
it's open source so so yeah
someone asks a serious question play the
grub asking playing in a classical
tourney tomorrow how do you deal with
nerves yeah nerves are natural nerves
mean that you're not you're still
getting experience when you when you get
a lot of experience playing in
tournaments usually the nerves will like
slowly go away but it sounds like maybe
you're still perhaps a newer player or
you're just in a situation that you're
not comfortable with which is natural
usually nerves will happen before a game
but like during a game if you just like
shift your energy to focus to focus on
the position then the nerves should go
away
I mean what else can I say don't worry
about the results like plates will learn
prioritize learning over winning that
can also maybe help with nerves if
you're not too worried about the results
then you can play a bit more freely be
open-minded
don't take draws don't cut game shorts
if you can play on and learn more so
that's what I'll say when's my next
chest stream probably tomorrow
anyway I am probably going to take off
we can go back to a beach s
where is leach s HS tile work okay we're
back on the HS feels like home thanks
for watching guys hopefully some people
enjoy this I apologize to the people who
came here looking for chess but got
troughs it's 30 people online not bad
yeah stay tuned I'm working on a stream
schedule so I'll try and be more more
what's the right word when it's late I
have trouble coming up with words more
transparent in terms of when I'll be
streaming I do have an announcement
about a match coming up but I I'll
probably save that for another time
so Joey Pike's enjoy the stream well
that makes it worth it cool guy
feel free to so just message me I'm
sometimes slow at getting back but I
will get back to you okay bye guys I am
going to raid on dress let's go tie on
dresses stream grade I am underscore on
yes good night